>> Jessica: TRANSPORTATION
SECRETARY PETE BUTTIGIEG FACING
CRITICISM FOR VACATIONING
OVERSEAS WHILE AMERICA WAS
FACING POTENTIAL CRISES.
THE FORMER MAYOR IN PORTUGAL
WHILE AMERICA PREPARED FOR A
RAILROAD STRIKE THAT COULD HAVE
SHUT DOWN THE SUPPLY CHAINS AND
TRAVEL.
MAKING THINGS WORSE POSTING THIS
VIDEO MAKING IT SEEM LIKE HE WAS
IN THE U.S.
>> OVER 200 FLIGHTS HAVE BEEN
DELAYED OR CANCELED SO TODAY THE
D.O.T. LAUNCHING AIRLINE
CUSTOMER SERVICE DASHBOARD.
FOR THE FIRST TIME YOU GO TO OUR
WEBSITE AND PREPARE AIRLINE
PRACTICES ALL IN ONE PLACE.
IF YOU ARE TRAVELING THIS
WEEKEND WERE IN A TIME, NO ERROR
DEPARTMENT HAS YOUR BACK.
>> Jessica: A SPOKESPERSON
SAID THE TRIP WAS LONG PLANNED
AND PEOPLE TO BUDGE TRAVELING ON
HIS OWN TIME ON URGENT ISSUES
ALL THE WAY.
DANA COME I WANT TO COME TO YOU.
THIS SOUNDS LIKE A ENFORCER WITH
A SQUEAKY CLEAN REPUTATION.
>> Dana: SO THE TRAPPINGS OF
HIS OFFICE HAVE RUINED HIS WHOLE
BRAND.
HIS BRAND SMALL TOWN MAYOR,
PROBLEMS OF HER, FOLK HERO, GOOD
GUY AND NOW ON PRIVATE JETS.
AND THE SECRETARY OF
TRANSPORTATION AND YOU HAVE A
POSSIBLE RAIL STRIKE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE THINK THIS IS A
MAJOR CRISIS AND YOU HAVE TO
DEAL WITH IT AND YOU ARE PHONING
IT IN FROM HOME FROM EUROPE?
THINK ABOUT THIS, ALSO, NANCY
HAS ALLOWED THESE PROXY RULES TO
GO ON SO LONG, DO YOU REMEMBER
WHAT THE CONGRESS MOMENT WAS
SAYING?
JONES, REMEMBER HIM?
THE WEDDING IN FRANCE?
AND VOTING BY PROXY BECAUSE HE
HAD COVID PROBLEMS QUESTION LIKE
THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
NOW INTERESTING PEOPLE DESERVE
TIME OFF BUT WHEN YOU ARE THE
SECRETARY, YOU HAVE TO TELL YOUR
LOVED ONES COME I KNOW THIS IS
NOT PLANT AND I PROMISED HIM AND
THIS IS DONE WE WILL GO ON
VACATION AND I WILL SPEND ALL MY
TIME FOCUSED ON YOU AND NOT TRY
TO PHONE IT IN ON A ZOOM CALL TO
THIS CABINET IN ORDER TO DEAL
WITH A RAIL STRIKE.
BUT I THINK THE WORST THING FOR
HIM HAS BEEN THAT HE HAS RUINED
HIS BRAND.
NOW, IF KAMALA HARRIS CAN GO
AGAINST HIM AND SAY, "YOU ARE
NOT THAT SMALL TOWN FOLK HERO
ANYMORE."
>> Katie: SHE WOULD LAUGH.
>> Jessica: JESSE, DO YOU
THINK PETE HAS RUINED HIS
REPUTATION?
>> Jesse: I'M GOING TO DEFEND
PETE HERE.
>> Katie: OH, WOW!
>> Jesse: BECAUSE THIS WAS A
PREPLANNED VACATION.
EVERYBODY DESERVES TIME OFF IN
AUGUST.
EVERYBODY ELSE IS OFF IN AUGUST,
YOU ARE OFF, WE ARE UP, I AM.
>> Katie: I'M NOT THE
SECRETARY OF TRANSPORTATION.
>> Jesse: OKAY, HE DIDN'T KNOW
THE STRIKE WAS COMING.
IT WAS PREPLANNED AND THE STRIKE
NEVER WENT DOWN.
DIDN'T GO DOWN.
SO, HE DID BRING A COAT WITH HIS
LITTLE PEN.
SO YOU CAN TELL HE WAS TRYING TO
GET ONE OVER ON US.
SO YOU CAN TELL HE FELT GUILTY
ABOUT IT.
BUT WHAT WAS HE SUPPOSED TO
WEAR?
WAS HE SUPPOSED TO WEAR AN OPEN
COLLAR SHIRT LOOKING OUT ON HIS
BRUNCH?
>> Jessica: THIS IS NOT GOOD.
>> Jesse: WITH THE WIND
BLOWING THROUGH HIS HAIR?
HE DID THE BEST UNDER THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
HE HAS A YOUNG THEY BECOME A
REMEMBER, PATERNITY.
>> Jessica: TWINS.
>> Jesse: PATERNITY FOR THE
TWINS, SO HE NEEDED A BREAK.
YOU NEED TO RECHARGE YOUR
BATTERIES SOMETIMES TO COME BACK
FULLY GEARED UP AND READY TO GO.
>> Katie: JESSE TRIED THAT.
GREG, YOU TRIED IT AND I THOUGHT
IT WAS GOOD TO.
>> Greg: BUT JESSE ONLY TAKES
VACATION AFTER SOMETHING
HAPPENS.
>> Dana: PREPLANNED.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: DID THEY GO TO
PORTUGAL?
>> Jessica: YEAH, PORTUGAL.
>> Greg: UNDERRATED.
I'VE MET MY WIFE THERE AND I MET
MY GIRLFRIEND THERE.
AND HER GIRLFRIEND.
I WILL BE HOME IN AN HOUR.
MAKE THE STEW.
HE PUTS THE GULL IN PORTUGAL.
YOU DON'T GET RECOGNIZED AND I
GO TO MEXICO, I VACATION IN
TIJUANA AND NOBODY RECOGNIZES ME
LIKE IN THE '80s.
HE DOESN'T GET BOTHERED BUT HE
DEFINITELY HAS GOT TO BE THE MAN
WHO KIND OF ADVERTISES WHY YOU
SHOULD VACATION IN AMERICA,
RIGHT?
YOU SHOULD BE GOING -- WE HAVE
WONDERFUL -- HE HAS THE
TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY, THE
RHODES SCHOLAR.
SO AS PEOPLE, COME TO THE SMALL
TOWN PURE TO COME TO OUR GREAT
PARK SPIRIT BUT YOU CAN'T JUST
SAY, GET THE HELL OUT OF THIS
PLACE.
I'M GOING TO PORTUGAL BECAUSE
PEOPLE, WHATEVER.
>> Jesse: SO YOU CAN ONLY
VACATION DOMESTICALLY IF YOU
WORK FOR THE GOVERNMENT?
>> Greg: IF YOU WORK FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION,
YES.
>> Jesse: IS THAT THE REAL?
>> Greg: THAT IS ACTUALLY IN
THE CONSTITUTION.
[LAUGHTER]
LOOK IT UP.
>> Katie: JESSE IS NOT ALLOWED
TO DO ACUPUNCTURE EVER AGAIN
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY
DID TO HIM BUT WOW, WELL, JESSE.
DURING OCTOBER 21 WHEN CARGO
SHIPS SITTING UP AT THE SHORES
NOT GETTING UNLOADED,
PETE BUTTIGIEG TAKES MATURE
GNOMIC MATERNITY LEAVE.
HE DIDN'T GIVE BIRTH AND HE IS
THE SECRETARY OF TRANSPORTATION.
IF YOU WERE A REPUBLICAN, LIKE
IF YOU ARE A REPUBLICAN --
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW.
IT IS CHANGING RAPIDLY.
>> Jessica: NOT THAT FAST.
>> Katie: IF A REPUBLICAN HE
WOULD HAVE BEEN HOUNDED OUT OF
OFFICE LIKE TOM PRICE AND HATED
AS A SECRETARY FOR DOING THIS
DURING A CRISIS.
PETE BUTTIGIEG TRIED TO ARGUE
EVEN THOUGH HE WENT ON THE
PORTUGAL VACATION AHEAD OF THE
RAILROAD STRIKE, HE WAS ABLE TO
GET A DEAL TO HAVE HER AT THE
STRIKE WHICH IS NOT TRUE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SAID
THEY GOT A DEAL THEY DID NOT GET
A DEAL.
IT WAS REJECTED BY THE RAILROADS
AND CONGRESS HAD TO BAIL HIM
OUT.
THAT IS ALSO NOT TRUE.
SO IF YOU'RE GOING TO BE THE
SECRETARY OF TRANSPORTATION OR
SOMETHING ELSE, THAT IS THE JOB
YOU ARE DOING AND YOU DON'T GET
TO LEAVE TWICE IN THE MIDDLE OF
A CRISIS.
>> Jesse: I'M SORRY BUT IT
ALWAYS HAPPENS DURING VACATION.
>> Jessica: IT MUST BE SAID
HIS TWINS WERE IN THE NICU.
SO LET'S BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT WAS
GOING ON THEN.
>> Jesse: OAK MY REALLY, THAT
IS WHY HE TOOK A LONG TERM?
>> Jessica: HE DIDN'T TAKE
THAT LONG PATERNITY BUT THERE
WAS A CRISIS.
>> Katie: BUT HE IS A DEPUTY,
THE WHOLE POINT.
>> Dana: YOU CAN'T GET CALLE